Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
[Le pedimos a Kiki Petrone que componga
una canción con las preguntas
que nos hicimos, al pensar
en los próximos 10 años.]
Espero que disfruten este tema
tanto como nosotros disfrutamos
de hacer nuestra música.
Pueden acompañar con las palmas
si es que así lo desean.
(Comienza la música)
(Palmas)
♪ No sé muy bien cómo vamos a hacer ♪
♪ No sé muy bien si lo podremos ver ♪
♪ Con ideas transformar y crecer ♪
♪ y en 10 años saber
quiénes vamos a ser. ♪
♪ La redes
¿serán sociales o individuales? ♪
♪ ¿Habrá más encuentros virtuales
o contactos reales? ♪
♪ Tanta pantalla táctil,
tan poco tacto que asusta ♪
♪ Un te amo ¿le ganará
a un comentario o un me gusta? ♪
♪ No sé muy bien cómo vamos a hacer ♪
♪ No sé muy bien... ♪
Sumo a alguien...
♪ ...y en 10 años saber
quiénes vamos a ser. ♪
♪ no nos pisemos al hablar...
podemos elegir crecer sin madurar ♪
♪ entendemos que es mejor
vivir de buen humor ♪
♪ la serendipia mantendrá vivo
nuestro niño interior ♪
♪ No sé muy bien cómo vamos a hacer ♪
♪ No sé muy bien si lo podremos ver ♪
♪ Con ideas transformar y crecer ♪
♪ y en 10 años saber
quiénes vamos a ser. ♪
♪ ¿Lograremos tener un mundo sustentable ♪
♪ basado en generar
las energías renovables ♪
♪ basado en no pensar
solamente en uno mismo ♪
♪ y considerar la Tierra
como un solo organismo? ♪
♪ No sé muy bien cómo vamos a hacer ♪
♪ No sé muy bien si lo podremos ver ♪
♪ Con ideas transformar y crecer ♪
♪ y en 10 años saber
quiénes vamos a ser. ♪
♪ ¿El arte para qué será? ♪
♪ ¿Será solo un espejismo,
una banalidad? ♪
♪ ¿Será una expresión de sentimiento
o será que la cantidad
le ganará a la calidad? ♪
Palmas...
♪ No sé muy bien cómo vamos a hacer ♪
♪ No sé muy bien si lo podremos ver ♪
♪ Con ideas transformar y crecer ♪
♪ y en 10 años saber
quiénes vamos a ser. ♪
♪ Vemos más humanos,
al menos los suficientes ♪
♪ para cuidar el mundo equitativamente ♪
♪ Dejar de pensar
solo en lo que conviene ♪
♪ Y lograr ayudar a los que menos tienen ♪
♪ No sé muy bien cómo vamos a hacer ♪
♪ No sé muy bien si lo podremos ver ♪
♪ Con ideas transformar y crecer ♪
♪ y en 10 años saber
quiénes vamos a ser. ♪
♪ La competencia por la atención
será perjudicial ♪
♪ Nuestro ego desatará
una guerra mundial ♪
♪ frente al poder seguiremos
siendo indiferentes ♪
♪ Importan más las empresas
que la propia gente ♪
♪ No sé muy bien cómo vamos a hacer ♪
♪ No sé muy bien si lo podremos ver ♪
♪ Con ideas transformar y crecer ♪
♪ y en 10 años saber
quiénes vamos a ser. ♪
♪ ¿Tendrá toda la gente
educación y calidad? ♪
♪ ¿Estudiaremos en un mundo
que no para de cambiar? ♪
♪ ¿Aprenderemos pues lo mismo
y a la misma edad ♪
♪ o seremos educados
de manera individual? ♪
♪ No sé muy bien cómo vamos a hacer ♪
♪ No sé muy bien si lo podremos ver ♪
♪ Con ideas transformar y crecer ♪
♪ y en 10 años saber
quiénes vamos a ser. ♪
♪ Sobre cómo vamos a gobernar
no tengo pistas ♪
♪ ¿Seremos comunidad o individualistas? ♪
♪ No sé muy bien cómo vamos a hacer ♪
♪ No sé muy bien si lo podremos ver ♪
♪ Con ideas transformar y crecer ♪
♪ y en 10 años saber
quiénes vamos a ser. ♪
♪ ¿Cómo construiremos
nuestras identidades? ♪
♪ ¿Viviremos con o dentro
de los celulares? ♪
♪ ¿Cómo nos informaremos de la realidad? ♪
♪ ¿Usaremos bien el tiempo
sin que mate la ansiedad? ♪
♪ No sé muy bien cómo vamos a hacer ♪
♪ No sé muy bien si lo podremos ver ♪
♪ Con ideas transformar y crecer ♪
♪ y en 10 años saber
quiénes vamos a ser. ♪
♪ No sé muy bien cómo vamos a hacer ♪
♪ No sé muy bien si lo podremos ver ♪
♪ Con ideas transformar y crecer ♪
♪ y en 10 años saber
quiénes vamos a ser. ♪
♪ No sé muy bien cómo vamos a hacer ♪
♪ No sé muy bien si lo podremos ver ♪
♪ Con ideas transformar y crecer ♪
♪ y en 10 años saber
quiénes vamos a ser. ♪
♪ No sé muy bien cómo vamos a hacer ♪
♪ No sé muy bien si lo podremos ver ♪
♪ Con ideas transformar y crecer ♪
♪ y en 10 años saber
quiénes vamos a ser. ♪
♪ No sé muy bien cómo vamos a hacer ♪
♪ No sé muy bien si lo podremos ver ♪
♪ Con ideas transformar y crecer ♪
♪ y en 10 años saber
quiénes vamos a ser. ♪
Kiki Petrone in da house...
(Aplausos)